♪
>> WELL IT OFTEN APPEARS INKNOCK
USE ON SOCIAL MEDIA SOITS OR
SEARCH ENGINES, THE TRUTH IS
THAT MISINFORMATION TAKES AWAY
OUR FREEDOM TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT OUR HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH OF OUR LOVED ONES,
DURING THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC
HEALTH MISINFORMATION HAS LED
PEOPLE TO RESIST WEARING MASKS
IN HIGH RISK SETTINGS TURN DOWN
TREATMENT AND CHOOSE NOT TO BE
VACCINATED.
>> WE HAVE IMPROVED
DISINFORMATION RESEARCH AND
TRACKING WITHIN THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S OFFICE FLAGGING
PROBLEMATIC POSTS FOR FACEBOOK
THAT SPREADS MISINFORMATION.
>> Bret: WHITE HOUSE FLAGGING
PROBLEMATIC POSTS FOR FACEBOOK.
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR SOME
REPUBLICANS FOR CAPITOL HILL.
>> I THINK IT'S REALLY SCARY TO
HAVE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THE WHITE
HOUSE COMPILING LISTS OF PEOPLE,
ORGANIZATIONS, AND THEN GOING TO
A PRIVATE COMPANY THAT BY THE
WAY IS A MONOPOLY, FACEBOOK.
AND SAYING YOU NEED TO CENSOR,
YOU NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
YOU NEED TO TELL THESE USERS,
THESE PRIVATE USERS AND PRIVATE
COMPANY WHAT THEY CAN OR CANNOT
SAY.
I THINK THAT THIS KIND OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN BIG
GOVERNMENT AND THE BIG MONOPOLY
CORPORATION BOY THAT IS SCARY
STUFF AND IT REALLY IS
CENSORSHIP, BRET.
>> Bret: WITH THAT LET'S BRING
IN OUR PANEL, BEN DOMENECH
PUBLISHER OF THE FEDERALIST.
KIM BUYERLY STRASSEL MEMBER OF
THE EDITORIAL "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" AND HAROLD FORD CEO OF
EMPOWERMENT INCLUSION CAPITOL.
KIMBERLY, LET ME START WITH YOU.
YOUR THOUGHT ON THIS.
>> THIS IS REMARKABLE.
ONLY LAST WEEK HAD THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SUE BIG TECH ARGUING THAT THEY
HAD VIOLATED FIRST AMENDMENT
STANDARDS BECAUSE THEY WERE
ACTING AS ARMS OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND HERE YOU HAVE THE WHITE
HOUSE AND JEN PSAKI, YOU KNOW,
GIVING TALKING POINTS THAT SEEM
TO LEAD CREDENCE TO WHAT IS KIND
OF A NOVEL LEGAL THEORY.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE STUFF LIKE
THIS PRESENTED IN COURT BECAUSE,
FIRST AMENDMENT USUALLY ONLY
NORMALLY APPLIES TO THE
GOVERNMENT BUT IF YOU CAN PROVE
THESE COMPANIES ARE TAKING
DICTATION FROM GOVERNMENT OUT OF
FEAR OF POLITICAL RETRIBUTION OR
ANYTHING ELSE, YOU CAN CLAIM
THAT THEY ARE STATE ACTORS.
>> Bret: HAROLD, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO COMBAT
MISINFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THE VACCINATION RATES IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND WITH SOME
GROUPS LOWER THAN IT NEEDS TO BE
AND SHOULD BE BECAUSE OF THAT
MISINFORMATION, BUT WHAT ABOUT
THE TACTIC?
>> WELL, THE TACTIC, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON, THE TACTIC,
WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE TO DO,
FACEBOOK OR THE WHITE HOUSE, ALL
OF IT WILL BE TRANSPARENT AND
DONE IN THE OPEN.
AND I WOULD AGREE WITH KIMBERLY.
IF THERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS IN
VIOLATION OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
I SUSPECT SOMEONE WILL CHALLENGE
IT AND IT WILL GO BEFORE A
COURT.
BUT, ONE OF THE CHIEF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND OBLIGATIONS
OF ANY GOVERNMENT, OF ANY
PRESIDENT IS PUBLIC HEALTH.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS WHITE
HOUSE IS COMING FROM.
WE HAD A FEW HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE DIE FROM THIS VIRUS AND
WE SEE THE DELTA VARIANT ON THE
RISE.
THE SURGEON GENERAL HAS EVER
RIGHT TO PUSH BACK AND EVERY
RIGHT TO USE EVERY TOOL AT HIS
DISPOSAL AND CERTAINLY SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE JUST THAT
NOW NOW I LISTENED TO YOUR
INTERVIEW WITH SENATOR HAWLEY
WHO IS AN EFFECTIVE PRESENTER.
HE IS RIGHT ON ONE SIDE LOOK AT
FACEBOOK AND CHALLENGES BECAUSE
OF ITS SIDE AND SUPPRESSING
COMPETITIVENESS AND INNOVATION.
THOSE QUESTIONS NEED TO BE
ANSWERED.
FACEBOOK HAS A PROCESS YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH IF YOU -- YOU ARE
I OR ANYONE IN THIS PANEL FLAG
SOMETHING ON FACEBOOK THAT MIGHT
INSIGHT VIOLENCE OR MIGHT BRING
VIOLENCE TO YOU OR CREATE A
PROBLEM IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO I SUSPECT THAT ALL OF THIS IS
BEING DONE IN THE OPEN.
ALL BEING DONE WITH TRANSPARENCY
ON IT.
IT WILL BE HARD FOR THEM TO
CHEAT, FOR THAT MATTER TO EXERT
SOME SORT OF INFLUENCE THAT'S
UNDO.
>> Bret: HERE'S THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
I WILL PLAY SUNDAY BITE FROM THE
HEAD OF THE W.H.O. RIGHT NOW AND
WE WILL GO ON THE BACK SIDE OF
IT.
>> THERE WAS PRETTY MUCH A PUSH
TO, YOU KNOW, ESPECIALLY REDUCE
ONE OF THE OPTIONS LIKE THE LAB
THEORY.
AS YOU KNOW, I WAS A LAB
TECHNICIAN MYSELF.
I'M AN IMMUNOLOGY JUST AND I
HAVE WORKED IN THE LAB AND LAB
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN I MYSELF HAVE
HAD ERRORS.
SO IT CAN HAPPEN.
>> Bret: THE BEGINNING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IF YOU SAID
ON FACEBOOK OR ON TWITTER THAT
THERE WAS A LEAK FROM THE LAB AT
WUHAN THAT CAUSED THIS
CORONAVIRUS TO SPREAD, THAT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS LISTED AS
DISINFORMATION.
IF YOU SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION
THAT THIS LANTD IS GOING TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION, THAT WAS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
DISINFORMATION AS IT EVOLVED IT
IS NOT DISINFORMATION AS THE
W.H.O. ACCEDED.
>> I'M SORRY TO DISAPPOINT
HAROLD TRANSPARENCY IS NOT A
WORD I ASSOCIATE WITH ANY
PROCESSES WITH FACEBOOK FLAGGING
ANY INFORMATION OR
DISINFORMATION.
IN FACT, THEY ARE COMPLETELY
OPAQUE IN TERMS OF THEIR
PROCESSES, WHAT THEY JUDGE AND
HOW THEY DEEM THINGS TO BE
DETERMINED, INCLUDING EVEN THEIR
FACT CHECKING PROCESS WHICH WE
PREVIOUSLY AT THE FEDERALIST RAN
INTO ON EXACTLY THIS ISSUE WHEN
IT CAME TO REPORTING AND WRITING
ABOUT THE LAB LEAK HYPOTHESIS
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
CERTAINLY FRUSTRATED US AS A
PUBLISHER BUT IT WAS ALSO FAR
MORE FRUSTRATING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF INDIVIDUAL, JUST
TRYING TO SHARE THEIR OWN
THOUGHTS, THEIR OWN INFORMATION,
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT, WHEN IT
CAME TO JEN PSAKI'S COMMENTS
TODAY, IS SHE MENTIONED THE FACT
THAT THIS WASN'T JUST ABOUT
FACEBOOK BUT ABOUT ALSO THE
COMPANIES IN OTHER AREAS THAT
THEY OWN.
THEY OBVIOUSLY OWN THE POPULAR
MESSAGING COMPONENT WHAT'S APP.
WHICH IS SOMETHING A LOT OF
PEOPLE USE TO COMMUNICATE.
WHAT WE SAW DURING THE HUNTER
BIDEN EXPERIENCE PEOPLE WEREN'T
EVEN ALLOWED TO DIRECT MESSAGE
U.S. REPORTING ABOUT THAT
ATLANTA ON TWITTER IS THIS GOING
TO BE A SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE FACEBOOK STARTS TO REACH
INTO THE PRIVATE COMMUNICATIONS
OF INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE GUISE
OF PREVENTING MISINFORMATION,
DISINFORMATION WHEN WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE REAL REASON THAT PEOPLE
ARE SEEING THESE DECLINES IN
TERMS OF VACCINATION RATES IS
THE KIND OF STORY THAT YOU HAD
EARLIER ABOUT L.A. COUNTY, ABOUT
THESE SCHOOL PROCESSES THAT SAY
REGARDLESS OF YOUR VACCINATION
STATUS, YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK AGAIN.
THAT DOES MUCH MORE DAMAGE TO
THE CAUSE OF VACCINATION THAN I
WOULD SAY ANY KIND OF SHARING OF
INFORMATION OR DEBATE AROUND THE
ORIGINATION OF THIS VIRUS OR ANY
OF THE OTHER RELATED ISSUES THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING.
>> Bret: HAROLD, I WILL GO BACK
TO YOU FOR REACTION HERE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT THE ACLU WOULD EMBRACE AND
SAY DON'T OVERSTEP THIS DON'T
OVERMIXING OF THE GOVERNMENT AND
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THIS PRIVATE
COMPANY THAT'S NOT CONTROLLED
OVER OVERSEEN AS A PUBLISHER.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE UNFORTUNATE
THING IS WE USED TO HAVE A LOT
MORE ROBUST COMMUNITY, INCLUDING
GROUPS LIKE THE ACLU THAT WOULD
BE TERRIFIED IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS, IN ESSENCE,
COERCING COMPANIES THIS WAY.
BECAUSE, REMEMBER, THE ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF POWER THE FEDS HAVE
OVER OUTSIDE BIG TECH GROUPS.
AND WE NOW HAVE DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE PROPOSE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD BASICALLY REQUIRE BIG TECH
TO GET THE SIGN-OFF OF FEDERAL
REGULATORS FOR ALMOST ANY ACTION
THEY TAKE.
AND ALL OF THIS IS GOING TO LEAD
POTENTIALLY TO SOME REALLY BIG
LAWSUITS.
>> Bret: HAROLD, LAST WORD.
>> IT'S NOT LOST ON ME ANY OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE, SAID.
I WOULD HOPE THAT PEOPLE WOULD
WANT TO GET A VACCINE BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO STOP WEARING A
MASK.
I WOULD HOPE PEOPLE ALSO REALIZE
THEY THAT WE MAY ALL GET THE
VACCINE AND MAY NOT BE ENOUGH OF
US VACCINATED THAT WE MAY HAVE
TO GO BACK TO WEARING IT THIS
WILL ALL PLAY OUT IN COURT.
I DON'T FAULT THIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR TRYING TO USE
EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE TO GET AS
MANY AMERICANS VACCINATED
BECAUSE ONE THICK WE DO KNOW IF
YOU ARE VACCINATED THE CHANCE OF
YOU GETTING SICK OR WORSE FROM
THIS VIRUS DECREASES IN
OVERWHELMING TO DRAMATIC TERMS
TO LESS THAN .1%.
NO AMERICAN NO PERSON IN PUBLIC
LIFE IN RESPONSIBLE PUBLIC LIFE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE NOT
TO GET THE VACCINE.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS TRYING TO DO IF IT'S
WRONG AND ILLEGAL TO BOTH OF MY
PANELISTS, LOOK, THE COURT